welcome to Hannity
all right the countdown continues there
it is 19 days until you send a message
to Joe Biden Kamala Harris Nancy Pelosi
Chucky Schumer and all the green New
Deal radical socialists in Congress are
you happy with record high gas prices
are you happy with a 41-year record high
of inflation are you happy with the open
borders of Joe Biden are you happy with
record violent crime record robberies
record murders uh how has the left's
defund dismantle Nobel law agenda worked
out for you are you happy with woke
propaganda being taught in your kids
schools are you happy with how the war
in Europe is being conducted are you
happy with how Joe Biden withdrew from
Afghanistan are you better off today
than when before Joe Biden became
president now tonight there is literally
nothing positive that I can see that
Democrats can run on they have done
nothing that improves the quality of
your life they have done nothing to make
this country a better place it is no
wonder Republicans are surging in the
polls here's a quote from the Wall
Street Journal Republican midterm
prospects Brighton in the closing weeks
of the election even the New York Times
quote Democrats feared Red October has
arrived and they see the writing is on
the wall and now Liberals are looking
for a scapegoat according to reports Joe
Biden will in fact be the Fall Guy if
Democrats get wiped out now let me say
this in defense of Joe Biden it's not
just Joe as a matter of fact I think
he's just taken orders it's pretty much
the entire Democratic radical Socialist
Party it's the climate Cults they're all
in this together you know everyone by
the way in a tight race is avoiding him
like the plague that is we have one
exception that's right the trust fund
brat in a hoodie John fetterman finally
took his working man you know hoodie
offer a day his Halloween costume and
put on a suit and tie to meet Joe Biden
apparently fetterman is the only
Democrat frankly dumb enough to appear
with the president in person now of
course that's news to Joe Biden the
cognitively struggling president seems
to think that he has been hitting the
campaign Trail really hard with more
than a dozen candidates who are they
take a look
John fetterman's going to appear with
you today
haven't been that many
characters
okay
okay
read it man get good educator you a
junkie I know sorry lost her for a
second
um why so angry Joey uh you know often
these sudden bursts of Fury accompany
people in significant cognitive decline
now you even have to wonder if Joe is
even aware of what a huge failure he
truly is or that his radical agenda is
hurt in the entire country is Joey just
upset that his own party is treating him
like a pariah is he upset he didn't get
his ice cream today is he angry that the
South that Saudi Arabia not only
rejected his numerous requests to
increase oil production but they ended
up decreasing it by two million barrels
a day and then they decided to humiliate
him in public and expose all of his
attempted collusion with the Saudis and
OPEC plus the pluses Russia to hide this
from you the American people and wait a
month before the announcement so an
election could occur let's be clear it's
not been a good week month or frankly
presidency for Joe Biden and his radical
Socialist Party and now once again he is
lashing out at our very own peter Ducey
Peter has the patience of Job you decide
just hoping to clarify for midterm
voters top domestic issues inflation or
abortion all important unlike you
there's no one thing it crosses the
board domestic SML foreign policy too
there's a multiple multiple multiple
issues and they're all important and so
and we ought to be able to walk and chew
gum at the same time you know they're
all Expressions
thank you you have the ability to walk
and chew gum you can't even stand and
read a teleprompter Joe especially if it
involves a number take a look
I signed into law a once in a generation
investment and Roads highways Bridges
railroads ports airports and so much
more
over a billion 200 trillion 200 billion
dollars but you know this is one Bridge
also tells a broader story there are
nearly forty five thousand say it again
45
000 Bridges across this country in poor
condition
now if you think that's bad look right
there take a look at your screen as Joe
tries to retrace his steps following his
speech another sad pathetic attempt to
find a way off the stage can somebody
just maybe put down you know I don't
know little footy patches or something
that he could walk on some path that he
can follow maybe a little light you know
so he knows to walk between the two the
lights or something Joe Biden look he's
not mentally mentally capable of being
president every day it becomes more and
more evident and apparent on this
program we're not afraid to bring you
those facts we have been right from the
beginning we are always honest about who
we are what we do I am a member of the
press I am up front that I am a
conservative talk show host this program
well we're like an entire newspaper we
do breaking news we do investigative
reporting we do opinion we tell you up
front we're a conservative I'm a
conservative we do cultural issues we do
Sports we're like the entire newspaper
unfortunately so many dishonest hope
earlier than now self-proclaimed
journalists are anything but journalists
they are upset that we are actually
covering the upcoming midterm elections
and they are Furious that we interview
Republican candidates and we also expose
the truth about their Democratic
opponents something that they should be
doing if they were real journalists but
they're too lazy to do and they're too
ideological to admit that they can't do
because they're in the tank for the
Democrats now keep in mind there are
three broadcast networks all liberal two
major cable networks all left-wing
almost every major paper in the country
dozens of dozens of websites little left
wing but they do nothing but carry the
water for Democrats they all buried
three weeks before the 2020 election
they buried the hunter Biden laptop from
Hell Scandal why to help Joe Biden win
the election add big Tech to the group
of people you weren't even allowed to to
tweet out the story or put it on
Facebook or put it on social media
because they viewed it as false
information it all turned out to be true
they all reported the phony Russia
collusion hoax as truth and they did
that for three long years they never
vetted Obama we did they let Joe Biden
hide in his basement bunker in 2020 and
by the way this year they're letting
other Democrats senatorial candidates
gubernatorial candidates do the same
thing in fact they're all actively now
supporting Democrats in the upcoming
midterms for example the New York Times
trashing Republican Herschel Walker as
quote a butcher of language but at the
very same time they praised John
fetterman for his his comprehensive
comprehension struggles and a piece
entitled John fetterman is a disabled
American who needs technology to do his
job so what the Washington Post
meanwhile employs a woman named Jennifer
Rubin for years she's pretended to be a
conservative columnist despite holding
zero conservative opinions now she just
loves socialist candidate John fetterman
writing quote the Democratic nominee for
you U.S Senate in Pennsylvania is
running a brilliant campaign this is
just the tip of the iceberg it's kind of
brilliant in its own way got to give
credit what credits do when you answer
no questions from the media uh you do
very few public events when you speak
you do it for less than 10 minutes and
then you shake a few hands don't answer
questions and go home and rest now I can
spend hours listing all the egregious
examples of the media mob support for
Democrats so before they accuse me of
doing something wrong for covering the
midterms the way they should be doing it
and interviewing Republicans they need
to take a long hard look in the mirror
and by the way for the record we have on
this program we have offered to give a
massive platform to many top Democratic
candidates we have invited on Raphael
Warnock we have offered John fetterman a
full hour on this program and three
hours on radio Mandela Barnes open
invitations we've been sending them we
don't get responses Gavin Newsom wanted
to have him on for the hour hour I've
offered hours on my radio show to
numerous Democratic candidates either
they don't respond or they're just too
gutless to come on they're unavailable
because
um they just won't come they're
scattered tough they don't want tough
questions they're scared of them anyway
they'd rather appear on msdnc or fake
news CNN where they're coddled and
protected so let me be clear we will
never stop bringing you our honest
perspective I now have started my 27th
year here at Fox and I am nowhere I'm
just we've just begun to start here
we're going to save America we're going
to solve our problems we always do it's
just a matter of when and with who
America's ignorant self-righteous
liberals they don't own the truth hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else